In Australia, scientists have
burned 10 pig carcasses
in an unprecedented experiment.
They are trying to answer a question from
the other side of the globe:
What happened to these 43 students
who disappeared in Mexico
two years ago?
The Mexican government
maintains that the students
from a teachers college were
kidnapped by a drug cartel.
They say their bodies were incinerated
atop a pile of wood and tires
in a trash dump in the town of Cocula.
Several bags of human remains, burned to ash,
were found in the dump and in a nearby river.
Last summer, fire scientist José Torero
went to Cocula to investigate
the government's story.
He saw no signs of a massive fire.
What's more, there was virtually no organic
material left in the remains.
That suggests they were
burned in a crematorium,
not an open-air fire.
He decided to do some
experiments to be sure.
Working with pig carcasses,
Torero used wood fuel
to burn anywhere
from one to four pigs at a time.
He found that over 700 kg
of wood was needed
to burn one pig carcass
to the point where
there was almost no
organic matter left.
Burning more than one body at a time
required even more fuel per body.
According to these results,
burning 43 bodies
would require over 30,000 kg of wood.
This suggests that the students’ bodies
were likely not burned in the dump.
Their final hours are still unaccounted for.
With the dumpsite ruled out,
it seems investigators should
continue to look elsewhere.